it's worth me recapping uh if anyone is
joining us right now what is going on
and what you're looking at live pictures
in colombo it's uh just past 1 p.m in
sri lanka on the day that president
rajapaksa was expected to formally
resign overnight we learned he'd fled to
the maldives
which is of course the island chain
neighboring sri lanka he went on a
military jet and he hasn't been heard
from since
he had pledged to stand down today
wednesday
after these mass protests that we've
been seeing uh for weeks for months now
in sri lanka
but now we're hearing the last sort of
half an hour or so that the prime
minister ranil victor messinger has now
been appointed acting president
something
many of the protests are clearly very
very angry about let's return to steph
vassen
who is in colombo clearly protesters
have lost their patience
absolutely and we saw some really
dramatic scenes here in the last couple
of minutes uh there was a lot of tear
gas fired at protesters and we've seen
people like branch in tear gas trying to
clean themselves up
really dramatic scenes people lying on
the pavement completely confused about
what was going on they really been
trying to chase the protesters out with
a lot of tear gas just in the last
couple of minutes
there's an ambulance now coming in there
are probably people injured as well it
was a huge attack of tear gas we saw the
smoke
really billowing
on top of the prime ministers oh that's
where the thousands of people here are
gathering even with gas masks they're
here but many of them i saw
young women i saw
i i saw young women i saw families i saw
older people they're all joining in in
this protest
and been really seriously hit
by these
tear gas attacks by police police is
trying to chase them away from the prime
minister's office they have been here
since this morning a couple of hours
already demanding his resignation but as
we know now he is now officially the
acting president i spoke to leaders of
the protest movement earlier this
morning they said we don't want him to
be in
in the president's office not even for a
single minute that's what they said
because the acting president could of
course hand over next week to a chosen
president chosen by parliament but they
say we don't want him to be even an
acting president not even for a single
minute well that's what's happening now
so they're really trying to make sure
that he leaves office there's an
ambulance here picking up some of the
people who have been injured
people were really running out they were
drenched
in water and they were really sprayed
seriously with tear gas so that's the
situation here at the prime minister's
office it seems police is quite serious
now of removing these protesters
using violence when we were talking a
little earlier uh
you referred to the military who have
been involved in in the violence in the
sense that they've been uh firing
volleys of tear gas on the crowd and so
on which has angered people and then you
mentioned that you you saw many many of
the military leaving the scene or
leaving the prime minister's office uh
have you got a better understanding of
what happened there is have they still
are they still out of the picture is a
situation calming down as a result of
that
[Music]
no it's not calming down that was what
the people here initially thought that's
why they all moved towards the prime
minister's office until there was this
tear gas used by security forces from my
position i can't see exactly who is
using who's firing tear gas at the
moment but what i saw was that a group
of military soldiers around 10 of them
were leaving this area and they were
smiling and they were pushed away by
protesters it hasn't changed anything on
the ground as far as i can see what we
are also hearing are reports that
protesters have taken over the state
television
premises and that they are actually
airing at the moment from
there but we can't confirm that
independently at the moment because the
situation is very fluid a lot of things
happening every minute here now sorry so
that's the latest here from the prime
minister's office
so it's just worth me recapping uh some
of the events of the last uh half an
hour or so sri lankan prime minister
ranil viklamasinga has now been
appointed
to be acting president uh the incumbent
got to buy a roger paxton now
overseas we believe in the maldives uh
possibly heading to another third
destination uh this is according to the
parliamentary speaker we got that news
uh in the last sort of hour or so
uh one of the reasons why protesters are
so frustrated so angry and uh we've seen
sort of the violence escalate if you
like uh because essentially they've just
they they feel uh they feel that
nobody is listening uh to their demands
what they wanted was the rajapaksa's out
of the country they managed to achieve
that
uh but now they're hearing that uh the
sri lankan prime minister ranil
vickermasingha again not not a popular
man clearly uh with the protesters is uh
has now been appointed acting president
and and they don't want him either um
steph i think you're still there step
tell us a bit more about ronald
vickermassinger because i believe you've
been talking to some protesters clearly
not a popular man
no not a popular man at all among the
protesters because they say he is
involved he has been supporting the
rajapaksa family he's been involved in
all their
misdeeds and mismanagement that has been
happening in the last couple of months
and also years he's been in government
before he's also known to have uh
ambitions to become the present very
strong ambitions i was told but they say
he is part of the gang he's part of this
family clan although he's not a direct
relative so they want him
to leave as well they say if he stays
here and he becomes the next president
nothing has changed and all all our
protests have been in vain so they
really think that this is now the moment
for the people in sri lanka all these
people here the thousands that have come
on to the streets and i'm i'm seeing
people from all walks of life from all
religions all kinds of backgrounds
they're gathered here now and they want
a real change they want the people's
demands to be listened to they want a
corruption to be abolished they want a
fairer share of the wealth they want
this crisis to be
addressed immediately they want to make
sure that people have enough fuel and
they have enough food and they also want
debts to be cancelled a lot of farmers
are now in debt because that
decision this very
this disastrous decision so to say from
the president to ban imports of chemical
fertilizer to go organic overnight well
a lot of farmers really
lost a lot of income because of that and
they have huge debt so
that's the situation that's why they're
here to demand real change they want the
people's council they want the people to
be involved in the decisions to be made
over the next coming hours next coming
days they don't want just parliament to
dictate what's going to be the future of
sri lanka that's the main reason that
they're all here and they're actually
risking a lot they have faced this
attack uh by tear gas by security forces
and they are
i mean several ambulances have been
going past already taking people to
hospital so the situation is quite
tense and has escalated significantly in
the last couple of hours
okay we'll leave it there for now
with
steph